The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PROFESSOR: Over the last
series of lectures, in
discussing filtering,
modulation, and sampling,
we've seen how powerful
and useful the
Fourier transform is.
Beginning with this lecture,
and over the next several
lectures, I'd like to develop
and exploit a generalization
of the Fourier transform, which
will not only lead to
some important new insights
about signals and systems, but
also will remove some of the
restrictions that we've had
with the Fourier transform.
The generalization that we'll
be talking about in the
continuous time case is referred
to as the Laplace
transform, and in the discrete
time case, is referred to as
the z transform.
What I'd like to do in today's
lecture is begin on the
continuous time case,
namely a discussion
of the Laplace transform.
Continue that into the next
lecture, and following that
develop the z transform
for discrete time.
And also, as we go
along, exploit
the two notions together.
Now, to introduce the notion of
the Laplace transform, let
me remind you again
of what led us
into the Fourier transform.
We developed the Fourier
transform by considering the
idea of representing signals
as linear combinations of
basic signals.
And in the Fourier transform,
in the continuous time case,
the basic signals that we picked
in the representation
were complex exponentials.
And in what we had referred to
as the synthesis equation, the
synthesis equation corresponded
to, in effect, a
decomposition as a linear
combination, a decomposition
of x of t as a linear
combination of complex
exponentials.
And of course, associated with
this was the corresponding
analysis equation that, in
effect, gave us the amplitudes
associated with the complex
exponentials.
Now, why did we pick complex
exponentials?
Well, recall that the reason was
that complex exponentials
are eigenfunctions of linear
time-invariant systems, and
that was very convenient.
Specifically, if we have a
linear time-invariant system
with an impulse response h of
t, what we had shown is that
that class of systems has the
property that if we put in a
complex exponential, we get out
a complex exponential at
the same frequency and with
a change in amplitude.
And this change in amplitude,
in fact, corresponded as we
showed as the discussion went
along, to the Fourier
transform of the system
impulse response.
So the notion of decomposing
signals into complex
exponentials was very intimately
connected, and the
Fourier transform was very
intimately connected, with the
eigenfunction property of
complex exponentials for
linear time-invariant systems.
Well, complex exponentials of
that type are not the only
eigenfunctions for linear
time-invariant systems.
In fact, what you've seen
previously is that if we took
a more general exponential, e
to the st, where s is a more
general complex number.
Not just j omega, but in fact
sigma plus j omega.
For any value of s, the complex
exponential is an
eigenfunction.
And we can justify that simply
by substitution into the
convolution integral.
In other words, the response to
this complex exponential is
the convolution of the impulse
response with the excitation.
And notice that we can break
this term into a product, e to
the st e to the minus s tau.
And the e to the st term can
come outside the integration.
And consequently, just carrying
through that algebra,
would reduce this integral to
an integral with an e to the
st factor outside.
So just simply carrying through
the algebra, what we
would conclude is that a complex
exponential with any
complex number s would generate,
as an output, a
complex exponential of the
same form multiplied by
whatever this integral is.
And this integral, of course,
will depend on what
the value of s is.
But that's all that
it will depend on.
Or said another way, what this
all can be denoted as is some
function h of s that depends
on the value of s.
So finally then, e to the st as
an excitation to a linear
time-invariant system generates
a response, which is
a complex constant depending
on s, multiplying the same
function that excited
the system.
So what we have then is the
eigenfunction property, more
generally, in terms of a more
general complex exponential
where the complex factor is
given by this integral.
Well, in fact, what that
integral corresponds to is
what we will define as the
Laplace transform of the
impulse response.
And in fact, we can apply this
transformation to a more
general time function that may
or may not be the impulse
response of a linear
time-invariant system.
And so, in general, it is this
transformation on a time
function which is the Laplace
transform of that time
function, and it's
a function of s.
So the definition of the Laplace
transform is that the
Laplace transform of a time
function x of t is the result
of this transformation
on x of t.
It's denoted as x of s, and as a
shorthand notation as we had
with the Fourier transform,
then we have in the time
domain, the time function x
of t, and in the Laplace
transform domain, the
function x of s.
And these then represent
a transform pair.
Now, let me remind you that
the development of that
mapping is exactly the process
the we went through initially
in developing a mapping
that ended up giving
us the Fourier transform.
Essentially, what we've done is
just broadened our horizon
somewhat, or our notation
somewhat.
And rather than pushing just a
complex exponential through
the system, we've pushed a more
general time function e
to the st, where s is a complex
number with both a
real part and an
imaginary part.
Well, the discussion that we've
gone through so far, of
course, is very closely related
to what we went
through for the Fourier
transform.
The mapping that we've
ended up with is
called the Laplace transform.
And as you can well imagine
and perhaps, may have
recognized already, there's a
very close connection between
the Laplace transform and
the Fourier transform.
Well, to see one of the
connections, what we can
observe is that if we look
at the Fourier transform
expression and if we look
at the Laplace transform
expression, where s is now a
general complex number sigma
plus j omega, these two
expressions, in fact, are
identical if, in fact,
sigma is equal to 0.
If sigma is equal to 0 so that
s is just j omega, then all
that this transformation is,
is the same as that.
Substitute in s equals j omega
and this is what we get.
What this then tells us is that
if we have the Laplace
transform, and if we look at
the Laplace transform at s
equals j omega, then that, in
fact, corresponds to the
Fourier transform of x of t.
Now, there is a slight
notational issue that this
raises, and it's very
straightforward to clean it up.
But it's something that it's--
you have to just kind of focus
on for a second to understand
what the issue is.
Notice that on the left-hand
side of this equation, x of s
representing the Laplace
transform.
When we look at that with sigma
equal to 0 or s equal to
j omega, our natural inclination
is to write that
as x of j omega, of course.
On the other hand, the
right-hand side of the
equation, namely the Fourier
transform of x of t, we've
typically written
as x of omega.
Focusing on the fact that
it's a function of
this variable omega.
Well, there's a slight
awkwardness here because here
we're talking about an argument
j omega, here we're
talking about an
argument omega.
And a very straightforward way
of dealing with that is to
simply change our notation for
the Fourier transform,
recognizing that the Fourier
transform, of course, is a
function of omega, but
it's also, in fact, a
function of j omega.
And if we write it that
way, then the two
notations come together.
In other words, the Laplace
transform at s equals j omega
just simply reduces both
mathematically and
notationally to the
Fourier transform.
So the notation that we'll now
be adopting for the Fourier
transform is the notation
whereby we express the Fourier
transform no longer simply as
x of omega, but choosing as
the argument j omega.
Simple notational change.
Now, here we see one
relationship between the
Fourier transform and the
Laplace transform.
Namely that the Laplace
transform for s equals j omega
reduces to the Fourier
transform.
We also have another important
relationship.
In particular, the fact that the
Laplace transform can be
interpreted as the Fourier
transform of a modified
version of x of t.
Let me show you what I mean.
Here, of course, we have
the relationship
that we just developed.
Namely that s equals j omega.
The Laplace transform reduces
to the Fourier transform.
But now let's look at the more
general Laplace transform
expression.
And if we substitute in s equals
sigma plus j omega,
which is the general form for
this complex variable s, and
we carry through some of the
algebra, breaking this into
the product of two exponentials,
z to the minus
sigma t times z to the
minus j omega t.
We now have this expression
where, of course, in both of
these there is a dt.
And now when we look at this,
what we observe is that this,
in fact, is the Fourier
transform of something.
What's the something?
It's not x of t anymore, it's
the Fourier transform of x of
t multiplied by e to
the minus sigma t.
So if we think of these two
terms together, this integral
is just the Fourier transform.
It's the Fourier transform of
x of t multiplied by an
exponential.
If sigma is greater than 0,
it's an exponential that
decays with time.
If sigma is less than 0,
it's an exponential
that grows with time.
So we have then this additional
relationship, which
tells us that the Laplace
transform is the Fourier
transform of an exponentially
weighted time function.
Now, this exponential weighting
has some important
significance.
In particular, recall that
there were issues of
convergence with the
Fourier transform.
In particular, the
Fourier transform
may or may not converge.
And for convergence, in fact,
what's required is that the
time function that we're
transforming be absolutely
integrable.
Now, we can have a time function
that isn't absolutely
integrable because, let's
say, it grows
exponentially as time increases.
But when we multiply it by this
exponential factor that's
embodied in the Laplace
transform, in fact that brings
the function back down
for positive time.
And we'll impose absolute
integrability on the product
of x of t times e to
the minus sigma t.
And so the conclusion, an
important point is that the
Laplace transform, the Fourier
transform of this product may
converge, even though
the Fourier
transform of x of t doesn't.
In other words, the Laplace
transform may converge even
when the Fourier transform
doesn't converge.
And we'll see that and we'll
see examples of it as the
discussion goes along.
Now let me also draw your
attention to the fact,
although we won't be working
through this in detail.
To the fact that this equation,
in effect, provides
the basis for us to figure out
how to express x of t in terms
of the Laplace transform.
In effect, we can apply the
inverse Fourier transform to
this, thereby to this, account
for the exponential factor by
bringing it over to
the other side.
And if you go through this, and
in fact, you'll have an
opportunity to go through this
both in the video course
manual and also it's carried
through in the text, what you
end up with is a synthesis
equation, an expression for x
of t in terms of x of
s which corresponds
to a synthesis equation.
And which now builds x of t out
of a linear combination of
not necessarily functions of the
form e to the j omega t,
but in terms of functions or
basic signals which are more
general exponentials
e to the st.
OK, well, let's just look at
some examples of the Laplace
transform of some
time functions.
And these examples that I'll
go through are all examples
that are worked out
in the text.
And so I don't want to
focus on the algebra.
What I'd like to focus on are
some of the issues and the
interpretation.
Let's first of all, look at the
example in the text, which
is Example 9.1.
If we take the Fourier transform
of this exponential,
then, as you well know, the
result we have is 1 over j
omega plus a.
And that can't converge
for any a.
In particular, it's only
for a greater than 0.
What that really means is that
for convergence of the Fourier
transform, this has to be
a decaying exponential.
It can't be an increasing
exponential.
If instead we apply the Laplace
transform to this,
applying the Laplace transform
is the same as taking the
Fourier transform of x of t
times an exponential, and the
exponent that we would
multiply by is e to
the minus sigma t.
So in effect, taking the Laplace
transform of this is
like taking the Fourier
transform of e to the minus at
e to the minus sigma t.
And if we carry that through,
just working through the
integral, we end up with a
Laplace transform, which is 1
over s plus a.
But just as in the Fourier
transform, the Fourier
transform won't converge
for any a.
Now what happens is that the
Laplace transform will only
converge when the Fourier
transform of this converges.
Said another way, it's when
the combination of a plus
sigma is greater than 0.
So we would require that, if I
write it over here, a plus
sigma is greater than 0.
Or that sigma is greater
than minus a.
So in fact, in the Laplace
transform of this, we have an
expression 1 over s plus a.
But we also require, in
interpreting that, that the
real part of s be greater
than minus a.
So that, essentially, the
Fourier transform of x of t
times e to the minus
sigma t converges.
So it's important to recognize
that the algebraic expression
that we get is only valid for
certain values of the
real part of s.
And so, for this example, we
can summarize it as this
exponential has a Laplace
transform, which is 1 over s
plus a, where s is restricted to
the range the real part of
s greater than minus a.
Now, we haven't had this issue
before of restrictions on what
the value of s is.
With the Fourier transform,
either it converged or it
didn't converge.
With the Laplace transform,
there are certain values of s.
We now have more flexibility,
and so there's certain values
of the real part of s for which
it converges and certain
values for which it doesn't.
The values of s for
which the Laplace
transform converges is--
the values are referred to as
the region of convergence of
the Laplace transform.
And it's important to recognize
that in specifying
the Laplace transform, what's
required is not only the
algebraic expression, but also
the domain or set of values of
s for which that algebraic
expression is valid.
Just to underscore that point,
let me draw your attention to
another example in the text,
which is Example 9.2.
In Example 9.2, we have an
exponential for negative time,
0 for positive time.
And if you carry through the
algebra there, you end up with
a Laplace transform expression,
which is again 1
over s plus a.
Exactly the same algebraic
expression as we had for the
previous example.
The important distinction is
that now the real part of s is
restricted to be less
than minus a.
And so, in fact, if you compare
this example with the
one above it, and let's just
look back at the answer that
we had there.
If you compare those two
examples, here the algebraic
expression is 1 over s plus
a with a certain region of
convergence.
Here the algebraic expression
is 1 over s plus a.
And the only difference between
those two is the
domain or region
of convergence.
So there is another
complication, or twist, now.
Not only do we need to generate
the algebraic
expression, but we also have to
be careful to specify the
region of convergence over
which that algebraic
expression is valid.
Now, later on in this lecture,
and actually also as the
discussion of the Laplace
transform goes on, we'll begin
to see and understand more
about how the region of
convergence relates to various
properties of the time function.
Well, let's finally look at one
additional example from
the text, And this
is Example 9.3.
And what it consists of is the
time function, which is the
sum of two exponentials.
And although we haven't
formally talked about
properties of the Laplace
transform yet, one of the
properties that we'll
see-- and it's
relatively easy to develop--
is the fact that the Laplace
transform of a sum is the sum
of the Laplace transform.
So, in fact, we can get the
Laplace transform of the sum
of these two terms as the sum
of the Laplace transforms.
So for this one, we know from
the example that we looked at
previously, Example 9.1, that
this is of the form 1 over s
plus 1 with a region of
convergence, which is the real
part of s greater
than minus 1.
For this one, we have a Laplace
transform which is 1
over s plus 2 with a region of
convergence which is the real
part of s greater
than minus 2.
So for the two of them together,
we have to take the
overlap of those two regions.
In other words, we have to
take the region that
encompasses both the real part
of s greater than minus 1 and
the real part of s greater
than minus 2.
And if we put those together,
then we have a combined region
of convergence, which is
the real part of s
greater than minus 1.
So this is the expression.
And for this particular example,
what we have is a
ratio of polynomials.
The ratio of polynomials,
there's a numerator polynomial
and a denominator polynomial.
And it's convenient to summarize
these by plotting
the roots of the numerator
polynomial and the roots of
the denominator polynomial
in the complex plane.
And the complex plane which
they're plotted is referred to
the s-plane.
So we can, for example, take the
denominator polynomial and
summarize it by specifying the
fact, or by representing the
fact that it has roots at s
equals minus 1 and at s
equals minus 2.
And I've done that in this
picture by putting an x where
the roots of the denominator
polynomial are.
The numerator polynomial has a
root at s equals minus 3/2,
and I've represented
that by a circle.
So these are the roots of the
denominator polynomial and
this is the root of
the numerator
polynomial for this example.
And also, for this example, we
can represent the region of
convergence, which is
the real part of s
greater than minus 1.
And so that's, in fact,
the region over here.
There is also, if I draw these,
just the roots of the
numerator and denominator of
polynomials, I would need an
additional piece of information
to specify the
algebraic expression
completely.
Namely, a multiplying constant
out in front
of the whole thing.
Well, this particular example,
has the Laplace transform as a
rational function.
Namely, it's one polynomial in
the numerator and another
polynomial in the denominator.
And in fact, as we'll see,
Laplace transforms, which are
ratios of polynomials, form
a very important class.
They, in fact, represent systems
that are describable
by linear constant coefficient
differential equations.
You shouldn't necessarily--
in fact, for sure you
shouldn't see
why that's true now.
We'll see that later.
But that means that Laplace
transforms that are rational
functions, namely, the ratio
of a numerator polynomial
divided by the denominator
polynomial, become very
important in the discussion
that follows.
And in fact, we have some
terminology for this.
The roots of the numerator
polynomial are referred to as
the zeroes of the Laplace
transform.
Because, of course, those are
the values of s at which x of
s becomes 0.
And the roots of the denominator
polynomial are
referred to as the poles of
the Laplace transform.
And those are the values of
s at which the Laplace
transform blows up.
Namely, becomes infinite.
If you think of setting s equal
to a value where this
denominator polynomial goes
to 0, of course, x
of s becomes infinite.
And what we would expect and,
of course, we'll see
that this is true.
What we would expect is that
wherever that happens, there
must be some problem
with convergence
of the Laplace transform.
And indeed, the Laplace
transform doesn't
converge at the poles.
Namely, at the roots of the
denominator polynomial.
So, in fact, let's focus in
on that a little further.
Let's examine and talk about the
region of convergence of
the Laplace transform, and how
it's associated both with
properties of the time function,
and also with the
location of the poles of
the Laplace transform.
And as we'll see, there are
some very specific and
important relationships and
conclusions that we can draw
about how the region of
convergence is constrained and
associated with the locations
of the poles in the s-plane.
Well, to begin with, we can, of
course, make the statement
as I've just made that
the region of
convergence contains no poles.
In particular, if I think
of this general rational
function, the poles of x of s
are the values of s at which
the denominator is 0.
Or equivalently, x
of s blows up.
And of course then, that implies
that the expression
has no longer converged.
Well, that's one statement
that we can make.
Now, there are some others.
And one, for example, is the
statement that if I have a
point in the s-plane that
corresponds to convergence,
then in fact any line in the
s-plane with that same real
part will also be a set of
values for which the Laplace
transform converges.
And what's the reason
for that?
The reason for that is that s
is sigma plus j omega and
convergence of the Laplace
transform is associated with
convergence of the Fourier
transform of e to the minus
sigma t times x of t.
And so the convergence only
depends on sigma.
If it only depends on sigma,
then if it converges for one
value of sigma--
I'm sorry, for a value of sigma
for some value of omega,
then it will converge for
that same sigma for
any value of omega.
The conclusion then is that the
region of convergence, if
I have a point, then
I also have a line.
And so what that suggests is
that as we look at the region
of convergence, it in fact
corresponds to strips in the
complex plane.
Now, finally we can tie
together the region of
convergence to the convergence
of the Fourier transform.
In particular, since we know
that the Laplace transform
reduces to the Fourier transform
when the complex
variable s is equal to j omega,
the implication is that
if we have the Laplace transform
and if the Laplace
transform reduces to the
Fourier transform when
sigma equals 0.
In other words, when s is equal
to j omega, then the
Fourier transform of x of t
converging is equivalent to
the statement that the Laplace
transform converges for sigma
equal to 0.
In other words, that
the region of
convergence includes what?
The j omega axis
in the s-plane.
So we have then some statements
that kind of tie
together the location of the
poles and the region of
convergence.
Let me make one other statement,
which is a much
harder statement to justify.
And I won't try to, I'll
just simply state it.
And that is that the region of
convergence of the Laplace
transform is a connected
region.
In other words, if the entire
region consists of a single
strip in the s-plane, it can't
consist of a strip over here,
for example, and a
strip over there.
Well, let me emphasize some of
those points a little further.
Let's suppose that I have a
Laplace transform, and the
Laplace transform that I'm
talking about is a rational
function, which is 1 over
s plus 1 times s plus 2.
Then the pole-zero pattern, as
it's referred to, in the
s-plane, the location of the
roots of the numerator and
denominator polynomials.
Of course, there is no
numerator polynomial.
The denominator polynomial
roots, which I've represented
by these x's, are shown here.
And so this is the pole-zero
pattern.
And from what I've said, the
region of convergence can't
include any poles and it
must correspond to
strips in the s-plane.
And furthermore, it must be
just one connected region
rather than multiple regions.
And so with this algebraic
expression then, the possible
choices for the region of
convergence consistent with
those properties are
the following.
One of them would be a region
of convergence to the
right of this pole.
A second would be a region of
convergence which lies between
the two poles as I show here.
And a third is a region of
convergence which is to the
left of this pole.
And because of the fact that I
said without proof that the
region of convergence must be
a single strip, it can't be
multiple strips.
In fact, we could not consider,
as a possible region
of convergence, what
I show here.
So, in fact, this is not a valid
region of convergence.
There are only three
possibilities associated with
this pole-zero pattern.
Namely, to the right of this
pole, between the two poles,
and to the left of this pole.
Now, to carry the discussion
further, we can, in fact,
associate the region of
convergence of the Laplace
transform with some very
specific characteristics of
the time function.
And what this will do is to
help us understand how for
various choices of the region
of convergence, the
interpretation that we
can impose on the
related time function.
Let me show you what I mean.
Suppose that we start with a
time function as I indicate
here, which is a finite duration
time function.
In other words, it's 0 except
in some time interval.
Now, recall that the Fourier
transform converges if the
time function has the property
that it's absolutely
integrable.
And as long as everything's
stays finite in terms of
amplitudes in a finite duration
signal, there's no
difficulty that we're going
to run into here.
Now, here the Fourier transform
will converge.
And now the question is, what
can we say about the region of
convergence of the Laplace
transform?
Well, the Laplace transform is
the Fourier transform of the
time function multiplied
by an exponential.
And so we can ask about whether
we can destroy the
absolute integrability of this
by multiplying by an
exponential that grows
to fast or decays
too fast, or whatever.
And let's take a look at that.
Suppose that this time function
is absolutely
integrable.
And let's multiply it by
a decaying exponential.
So this is now x of t times z
to the minus sigma t if I
think of multiplying
these two together.
And what you can see is that
for positive time, sort of
thinking informally, I'm helping
the integrability of
the product because I'm pushing
this part down.
For negative time,
unfortunately, I'm making
things grow.
But I don't let them grow
indefinitely because there's
some time before which
this is equal to 0.
Likewise, if I had a growing
exponential, then for a
growing exponential for negative
time, or for this
part, I'm making
things smaller.
For positive time, eventually
this exponential is growing
without bound.
But the time function
stops at some point.
So the idea then kind of is
that for a finite duration
time function, no matter what
kind of exponential I multiply
by, whether it's going this way
or going this way, because
of the fact that essentially the
limits on the integral are
finite, I'm guaranteed that I'll
always maintain absolute
integrability.
And so, in fact then, for a
finite duration time function,
the region of convergence
is the entire s-plane.
Now, we can also make statements
about other kinds
of time functions.
And let's look at a time
function which I define as a
right-sided time function.
And a right-sided time function
is one which is 0 up
until some time, and then it
goes on after that, presumably
off to infinity.
Now, let me remind you that the
whole issue here with the
region of convergence has to do
with exponentials that we
can multiply a time function by
and have the product end up
being absolutely integrable.
Well, suppose that when I
multiply this time function by
an exponential which,
let's say decays.
But an exponential e to the
minus sigma 0 t, what you can
see sort of intuitively is
that if this product is
absolutely integrable, if I were
to increase sigma 0, then
I'm making things even better
for positive time because I'm
pushing them down.
And whereas they might be worse
for negative time, that
doesn't matter because
before some time the
product is equal to 0.
So if this product is absolutely
integrable, then if
I chose an exponential e to the
minus sigma 1t where sigma
1 is greater than sigma 0, then
that product will also be
absolutely integrable.
And we can draw an important
conclusion about that, about
the region of convergence
from that.
In particular, we can make the
statement that if the time
function is right-sided and if
convergence occurs for some
value sigma 0, then in fact,
we will have convergence of
the Laplace transform for all
values of the real part of s
greater than sigma 0.
The reason, of course, being
that if sigma 0 increases,
then the exponential decays even
faster for positive time.
Now what that says then thinking
another way, in terms
of the region of convergence
as we might draw it in the
s-plane, is that if we have a
point that's in the region of
convergence corresponding to
some value sigma 0, then all
values of s to the right of that
in the s-plane will also
be in the region
of convergence.
We can also combine that with
the statement that for
rational functions we know that
there can't be any poles
in the region of convergence.
If you put those two statements
together, then we
end up with a statement that if
x of t is right-sided and
if its Laplace transform is
rational, then the region of
convergence is to the right
of the rightmost pole.
So we have here a very important
insight, which tells
us that we can infer some
property about the time
function from the region
of convergence.
Or conversely, if we know
something about the time
function, namely being
right-sided, then we can infer
something about the region
of convergence.
Well, in addition to right-sided
signals, we can
also have left-sided signals.
And a left-sided signal is
essentially a right-sided
signal turned around.
In other words, a left-sided
signal is one that is
0 after some time.
Well, we can carry out
exactly the same
kind of argument there.
Namely, if the signal goes off
to infinity in the negative
time direction and stops some
place for positive time, if I
have an exponential that I can
multiply it by and have that
product be absolutely
integrable.
And if I choose an exponential
that decays even faster for
negative time so that I'm
pushing the stuff way out
there down even further,
then I enhance the
integrability even more.
And you might have to think
through that a little bit, but
it's exactly the flip
side of the argument
for right-sided signals.
And the conclusion then is that
if we have a left-sided
signal and we have a point, a
value of the real part of s
which is in the region of
convergence, then in fact, all
values to the left of that point
in the s-plane will also
be in the region
of convergence.
Now, similar to the statement
that we made for right-sided
signals, if x of t is left-sided
and, in fact, we're
talking about a rational Laplace
transform, which we
most typically will.
Then, in fact, we can make the
statement that the region of
convergence is to the left of
the leftmost pole because we
know if we find a point that's
in the region of convergence,
everything to the left of that
has to be in the region of
convergence.
We can't have any poles in the
region of convergence.
You put those two statements
together and it says it's to
the left of the leftmost pole.
Now the final situation is the
situation where we have a
signal which is neither
right-sided nor left-sided.
It goes off to infinity for
positive time and it goes off
to infinity for negative time.
And there the thing to kind of
recognize is that if you
multiply by an exponential, and
it's decaying very fast
for positive time, it's going
to be growing very fast for
negative time.
Conversely, if it's decaying
very fast for negative time,
it's growing very fast
for positive time.
And there's this notion
of trying to balance
the value of sigma.
And in effect, what that says
is that the region of
convergence can't extent
too far to the left or
too far to the right.
Said another way for a two-sided
signal, if we have a
point which is in the region
of convergence, then that
point defines a strip in the
s-plane that takes that point
and extends it to the left until
you bump into a pole,
and extends it to the right
until you bump it into a pole.
So you begin to then see that
we can tie together some
properties of the region
of convergence and the
right-sidedness, or
left-sidedness, or
two-sidedness of the
time function.
And you'll have a chance to
examine that in more detail in
the video course manual.
Let's conclude this lecture by
talking about how we might get
the time function given the
appliance transform.
Well, if we have a Laplace
transform, we can, in
principle, get the time
function back again by
recognizing this relationship
between the Laplace transform
and the Fourier transform, and
using the formal Fourier
transform expression.
Or equivalently, the formal
inverse Laplace transform
expression, which
is in the text.
But more typically what we would
do is what we've done
also with the Fourier transform,
which is to use
simple Laplace transform pairs
together with the notion of
the partial fraction
expansion.
And let's just go through
that with an example.
Let's suppose that I have
a Laplace transform as I
indicated here in its pole-zero
plot and a region of
convergence which is to the
right of this pole.
And what we can identify from
the region of convergence, in
fact, is that we're
talking about a
right-sided time function.
So the region of convergence is
the real part of s greater
than minus 1.
And now looking down at the
algebraic expression, we have
the algebraic expression for
this, as I indicated here,
equivalently expanded in a
partial fraction expansion, as
I show below.
So if you just simply combine
these together, that's the
same as this.
And the region of convergence is
the real part of s greater
than minus 1.
Now, the region of
convergence of--
this is the sum of two terms,
so the time function is the
sum of two time functions.
And the region of convergence of
the combination must be the
intersection of the region
of convergence
associated with each one.
Recognizing that this is to the
right of the poles, that
tells us immediately that each
of these two then would
correspond to the Laplace
transform of a right-sided
time function.
Well, let's look at
it term by term.
The first term is the factor 1
over s plus 1 with a region of
convergence to the right
of this pole.
And this algebraically
corresponds
to what I've indicated.
And this, in fact, is similar
to, or a special case of the
example that we pointed to at
the beginning of the lecture.
Namely, Example 9.1.
And so we can just simply
use that result.
If you think back to that
example or refer to your
notes, we know that time
function of the form e to the
minus a t gives us the Laplace
transform, which is 1 over s
plus a with the real part of
s greater than minus a.
And so this is the Laplace
transform of the first.
Or, I'm sorry, this is the
inverse Laplace transform of
the first term.
If we now consider the pole at
s equals minus 2, and here is
the region of convergence that
we originally began with.
In fact, we can having removed
the pole at minus 1, extend
this region of convergence
to this pole.
And we now have an algebraic
expression, which is minus 1
over s plus 2, the real part
of s greater than minus 1.
Although, in fact, we can
extend the region of
convergence up to the pole.
And the inverse transform of
this is now, again, referring
to the same example, minus
e to the minus 2t
times the unit step.
And if we simply put the two
terms together then, adding
the one that we have here to
what we had before, we have a
total inverse Laplace transform,
which is that.
So essentially, what's happened
is that each of the
poles has contributed an
exponential factor.
And because of the region of
convergence being to the right
of all those poles, that is
consistent with the notion
that both of those terms
correspond to
right-sided time functions.
Well, let's just focus for a
second or two on the same
pole-zero pattern.
But instead of a region of
convergence which is to the
right of the poles as we had
before, we'll now take a
region of convergence which
is between the two poles.
And I'll let you work through
this more leisurely in the
video course manual.
But when we carry out the
partial fraction expansion, as
I've done below, we would now
associate with this pole a
region of convergence
to the right.
With this pole, a region of
convergence to the left.
And so what we would have is the
sum of a right-sided time
function due to this pole.
And in fact it's of the form e
to the minus t for t positive.
And a left-sided time function
due to this pole.
And in fact, that's of
the form e to the
minus 2t for t negative.
And so, in fact, the answer
that we will get when we
decompose this, use the partial
fraction expansion,
being very careful about
associating the region of
convergence of this pole to the
right and of this pole to
the left, we'll have then, when
we're all done, a time
function which will be of the
form e to the minus t times
the unit step for t positive.
And then we'll have a term
of the form e to the--
I'm sorry, this would be e to
the minus 2t since this is at
minus 2 and this
is at minus 1.
This would be a plus sign and
this would be minus e to the
minus t for t negative.
And you'll look at that a little
more carefully when you
sit down with the video
course manual.
OK, well, what we've gone
through, rather quickly, is an
introduction to the
Laplace transform.
And a couple of points to
underscore again, is the fact
that the Laplace transform is
very closely associated with
the Fourier transform.
And in fact, the Laplace
transform for s equals j omega
reduces to the Fourier
transform.
But more generally, the Laplace
transform is the
Fourier transform of x of t with
an exponential weighting.
And there are some exponentials
for which that
product converges.
There are other exponentials for
which that product has a
Fourier transform that
doesn't converge.
That then imposes on the
discussion of the Laplace
transform what we refer to as
the region of convergence.
And it's very important to
understand that in specifying
a Laplace transform, it's
important to identify not only
the algebraic expression, but
also the values of s for which
it's valid.
Namely, the region
of convergence
of the Laplace transform.
Finally what we did was to tie
together some properties of a
time function with things that
we can say about the region of
convergence of its Laplace
transform.
Now, just as with the Fourier
transform, the Laplace
transform has some very
important properties.
And out of these properties,
both are some mechanisms for
using the Laplace transform
for such systems as those
described by linear constant
coefficient
differential equations.
But more importantly, the
properties will help us.
As we understand them further,
will help us in using and
exploiting the Laplace transform
to study and
understand linear time-invariant
systems.
And that's what we'll
go on to next time.
In particular, talking about
properties, and then
associating with linear
time-invariant systems much of
the discussion that we've
had today relating
to the Laplace transform.
Thank you.